je veux que vous fassiez honneur à cet
établissement vous êtes particulièrement
doué mais je vous rappelle que vous
devez payer vos études je n'ai droit à
aucune aide financière et doit donner 60
mille dollars à l'université la semaine
prochaine et ça c'est si je mange pas
bienvenue dans la vraie vie
monsieur woerth ça c'est ton plan pour
payer les frais de scolarité
moi j'ai personnes qui me finance mes
études supérieures tu t'es fait arnaquer
on est très loin des courbes habituel tu
vas tu envolé pour un pays qui étaient
complètement inconnus et on tu parle
même pas la langue
tu te rends compte que c'est une idée de
tarés enchanté moi c'est du vent rithy
firth et voici la banque
pourquoi la banque c'est toujours la
banque qui gagne c'est pour ça qu'on n'a
pas besoin de tricher vos calculs en
l'air parfait j'ai oublié un détail non
nos programmeurs of installer une porte
dérobée dans le code tu l'as vu tu es
venu me trouver ça c'est pour les ennuis
comptes a causé et si tu as envie de
rester ici pour te confronter aux vrais
business je suis là à salaires à sept
chiffres les 18 premiers mois j'ai hâte
de voir toute la question
alors qu'est ce que t'en dis qu'est ce
que vous croyez
de m'appeler agent chez verser le fbi et
dans les enlèvements maintenant votre
vin versés aux officiels raquette
t'imagines même pas dans quel bordel tu
t'es fou rire pourquoi j'y laisse bien
you qu est ce que tu te demander si tu
faisais quelque chose de mal à toi de me
dire alors j'ai mis sur a confié à tmz
que c'est moi qui ai message maman tu es
ses portes à tu veux un boulot plus
calme va coller d'état par la poste
tu veux avoir bonne conscience pose dans
l'humanitaire mais si tu veux tu acheté
ta [ __ ] deal et que ton post d'aller
faire démonter il va tu prends ta raclée
du rapid illico en demandant qu'on dise
que vous vous l'examen d'entrée à 48
heures pour ben rhodes j'ai bien une
solution pour me sortir de là mais
schirrhein vraie passion c'est des
crocodiles ouais il me rappelle tous les
[ __ ] qui veulent me saigne à blanc
pas faire quoi